now that tail propels a 20,000 RPMs okay
it's made out of 40 pieces if one piece
is missing it would not function okay
the question is the following if there
is design it requires designer simple
argument did you guys know the prophet
peace be upon him
said Prophet peace upon him said the one
who gives a his will be a shade on and
we here every Friday and Sunday doing da
to many people aldah seven Shas two
weeks
ago two Shas last week two Shas last
week you can support this brother and
sisters with the material aldah some of
them we pay for some of them aldah we
get for free as you guys donated to the
Salah plus project aldah brothers and
sisters if you can donate whatever you
can it will help our operations to have
a cameraman an editing team and some of
the brothers who come and dedicate their
time and effort to giving da inshah the
link is in the description box below
thank you keep up the good thank you do
you do you have you read the Quran
before sister no can I give you a free
copy oh do you know no I'm just not
religious that's fine is there a reason
you're not do you believe in God no do
you don't believe in God I can prove God
exists in 2
minutes have you got 2 minutes okay all
right no problem so my argument is the
following yeah that let me give you
something to do with
nature let's talk about
let's talk about bees you know bees okay
good do you know bees have intelligence
so for example the way the bees find
nectar is that they all go out in
different directions from the the from
The Colony and what they do is when the
bee goes to a specific distance so let's
suppose The Hive is here and it travels
to Oxford Circus it realizes there's
nectar there it comes back when it comes
back there was a man called a a I think
it was a German biologist his name was
Carver fres so he was observing them and
he was realizing that when you look at
the bees it looks like they are dancing
I mean not dancing it's just they're
scattered around but when you look
closely the bee that went and found the
nectar when he comes back he actually
starts to wiggle his tail and dance in a
specific pattern so he was like why are
they doing that so when he noticed and
did that he was looking at them he put a
specific mark on the back of the bee to
observe them and then he realized that
bees have a a solar Compass so they know
where the sun is and that's how they use
the directions to find the nectar the
bee when it was dancing it was telling
the other bees in the colony the
direction and the distance of where the
nectar is now would you accept that that
be has
Intelligence yeah it's just like natural
selection isn't it it's just develop
that behavior okay so recent studies
show I don't know if you've heard of
someone called um oh I forgot his name
uh Noble something Dennis Noble he's
he's he's a he's a scientist um he's
against
he's kind of against the Darwin Theory
Dawkin theory yes he doesn't believe in
uh natural selection he believes in
targeted selection so what they notice
is that for example they you have the
you know the cell so Darwin when he was
talking about the cell he talked about
the cell as if it's something very
simple and over time it developed to be
something complex we believe that's not
true now because Dennis Noble when he
studies the cell he realizes the
following so imagine my hand is the
nucleus cuz you know the cell has a
nucleus so imagine the nucleus is my
hand and imagine the membrane of the
cell is in Scotland yeah he realized
that when he looks closely there's
something called I think they called
tubulins which is that the cell membrane
sends information to the nucleus now
what's in the nucleus is genomes yes and
there's genes inside it which have have
the DNA now do you know DNA DNA has
information now information requires
intelligence am I correct good the
question I'm asking is the F it's read
by Pro it's read by um protein okay
reading means what no but it's not
actually readed it's each each one of
the faes yeah the trip is cuz it's the
codon codes for a specific amino acid
and then the chain of themin then You'
got the different form D stru to do with
the bonding between the co bonding
bonding I don't think that's like
intelligence how can it not be look you
said to me bonding reading and also it
has proof reading do you know it has
proof reading for example you know that
you know when the DNA from the chrom
stop codons and it just tell it
literally it doesn't code for anything
it just makes it pause and then it
creates and then it creates the next
okay chain but when you say it creates
what gave it that prior in knowledge for
it to do the action because the the DNA
look you know when the chromosomes meet
together you know when the DNA
replicates there are mistakes from one
in every 10,000 there are billions of
copy copying that's some mutation no no
no one second look there's random
mutation and we're saying about targeted
mutation yeah what I'm saying is that
you know when the copying happens
usually there are errors one in one in
every 10,000 but it's not necessarily an
error it's it's is a good thing it's why
we have mutations and it's like crossing
over between the chromos okay good so so
so what I'm just saying is the following
so whatever you want to call it there's
mistakes that happen and they're one in
10,000 the scientist usually say now
what happens is one in 10,000 is okay
but when there are billions of copies
happening those one in 10,000 turns into
millions now good something interesting
happens when that happens it goes
through another proof radar near the
cell near the membrane if I'm not
mistaken it reduces this mistake from 1
in 10,000 to 11 in0 billion the question
I have to ask is the following all of
this mechanism that we see all of this
copying and error correcting this is an
order now the question I'm asking is the
following my dear DNA has information
yes or WR am I correct yeah information
requires intelligence am I right or
wrong not necessarily can you give me
one example anywhere that information
doesn't require intelligence but I
wouldn't you know we've described this
information that's how our
interpretation of it but it's really
just to do with um the way that like it
all interacts with each other but but
but how okay so if I see for example let
me give you an example there was a
there's a scientist called uh Michael
Bei he's he talks about the flugum plum
is the tail of a bacteria okay it is
composed of 40 pieces if I showed you
the picture and I did not tell you what
this is you will say this is a probably
it looks like an engine it's like a
motor now the question is the following
when I bring a engine of a Ferrari and
we look at it and go wow it's composed
of so many parts that looks like in some
someone smart done that we're talking
about a flagellum that on a teaspoon 4
billion of them can fit in that's how
it's on a nano level yeah and you're a
smart woman I'm sure you studied this
yeah now that tail propels at 20,000
RPMs okay it's made out of 40 pieces if
one piece is missing it would not
function okay the question is the
following it is a motar it's composed of
40 pieces it's has a it propels the
bacteria that shows design if there is
design it requires designer simple
argument not necessary but you need to
tell me why and I'll accept it to do
with um coincidence and the fact that
that you think if you think about and
probability and the fact that the UN if
you if you believe the universe is you
know infinitely large and there are
infinite possibilities for things to
happen and you know and eventually like
life will just occur because of things
okay I for your name Dana sister Dana
from a log logical and rational point of
VI you're a very smart intelligent girl
do you think we can call it a
coincidence when you said the universe
is so vast all things are possible let
me give you an example if a thing to
make arguments if I said I want a
Ferrari and I have this cup and it's
empty there's nothing in it no atoms
nothing what has time and infin infinite
possibilities got to do with making
something that the element to make that
thing is not in the C for example if I
have nothing in the cup giving it
billion amount of years is irrelevant to
the equation cuz the elements to make a
Ferrari or a strawberry cheesecake or a
a a building if it's not in that cup
time is irrelevant to the equation do
you get what I'm trying to say I'm not
going to be able to explain to you how
like energy and matter initially started
if you look at but we do know it started
yeah but if you look at this in within
the sun you've got hydrogens coming
together to form helium like you can
create things that don't exist prior
like elements can be created but the
fact that the fact that they interact
and become this thing shows that it has
the properties for that to develop the
point we're seeing is the following I
get what you're saying like there's
absolutely nothing yes what I'm talking
about is the absence of something we
know the universe began to exist the the
question we're asking is what caused it
to begin because we look around us if we
want to be moral if we want to be
consistent we look you use rationality
and logic today you came here today you
walked and said oh my God I know that
guy he's on Tik Tok yeah okay you didn't
say oh my gosh maybe he's in The Matrix
maybe he doesn't even exist maybe I'm
not real you use your rationality and
logic today when you're going to cross
that road you're going to look left and
right am I right or wrong when you well
I hope you do got hit by a car not that
long was he looking left or right even
know okay okay okay okay then that's
that's again that was an accident so I
hope you're well yeah yeah that's good
so the point I'm saying is this sister
when you woke up in the morning you knew
you was in your bed yeah you knew when
you go downstairs what's your favorite
breakfast I don't eat breakfast I don't
blame you but uh is there anything you
do in the morning coffee just whatever
yeah coffee okay good you know when you
go down if you went to your coffee
machine opened it and saw a uh a
rectangular looking object you're going
to think what an earth is that you will
not say oh that's a possibility we live
in a universe that all things can happen
it's like we won't be able to do science
do you get it I I understand what you're
saying about like that it's just like it
makesense there's order stability
uniformity I don't remember exactly
there something about like like the
watch maker and like how they talk about
the watch maker argument yes all that
stuff and like I do I do understand that
but also for me it's more just like I
can't prove the non-existence of
something so I feel like it's up to the
religious person to prove the existence
of it okay but do you not think as a
person because I could just you know I
mean I'm sure you've heard of a Flying
Spaghetti Monster and all of these
things I you can't prove to me that that
doesn't exist you can't prove to me that
these things well I I can't because the
thing is what I'm saying is the same way
that I can't prove to you that God
doesn't exist I can I can prove to you
God exists now the thing is I believe
you're having a great leap of faith
because usually that should come from us
religious people just put your faith in
God and no as Muslims we're a little bit
different we say hold on a second Allah
tells us in the Quran use your rational
and logical Allah doesn't tell us have
Blind Faith and jump that's the reason
why I'm trying to provoke you a little
bit in the sense where you're having a
great leap of faith you're saying I you
know I don't know and just I'm saying
let's talk with certainty we accept that
if there's information there has to be
intelligence if there is something
everything you're wearing right now even
that Lily on your hair has a purpose you
get what I'm trying to say so the point
is this my dear sister we're seeing that
for example there are things that you
don't see that you believe in your
Consciousness do you have a
Consciousness yeah but I certainly don't
ful understand what Consciousness
actually okay but do you believe do you
believe you have Consciousness okay can
I see it can I touch I'm not saying that
you necessarily need to have the five
sent there are things that are
metaphysical example like you know
believing in like love or you know even
money to be honest it doesn't actually
have the value we it I agree um so I'm
not saying it's just the five basic
senses but perfect I don't know exactly
but but but just just I'm going to wrap
up I know your code is freezing as well
okay sorry yeah so what I'm trying to
say is this is Stu if you think about it
scientists and people and science
doesn't actually if you look look at U
Darwin's book he said in my wildest
extreme fluctuations I he was never a
den of God did you know that he was
actually a person who believed in God if
you read his books he became agnostic
when it came to seeing evil in the world
but when it came to his evolutionary
theory he never at his wildest part
that's why he was really scared to
publish his fin is cuz he was like oh no
I've killed God like I've just just and
then he found out that someone else was
about to publish it and he was like okay
let me quickly do the Origin of Species
good he was scared of the church yeah
like but but but he always had believe
in God so the point I'm saying is just
looking at it from a logical perspective
yeah everything that begins to exist has
a course the universe began to exist it
requires a course I feel like we're
using our basic understanding like even
that thing about like everything needs
to have a cause everything that begins
to exist yeah but it's just like we're
only saying that based off of what we
can observe got in front of us but
that's how we do science otherwise we
can't do science no but I think okay so
my little thing is like if we I believe
that if every single like religious or
fictional whatever it is like books
stories anything completely cease to
exist if you came back in billions of
years time whatever it wouldn't come
back exactly as it was I don't I don't
read the Quran or the Bible or whatever
it is would come back exactly as it is
however if you got rid of every single
element of scientific understanding if
you came back it would all exist again
maybe under slightly different like
understanding of it but gravity will
always be gravity whenever you do the
same experiment and get the same result
you drop something it will always fall
to the ground cause and effect yeah no
but what I'm saying is that's why for me
I just love science like like I'm I'm
very happy just believing that I am a
Muslim I have no problem with science I
need science in my life and not only
that there were many Muslim um
scientists in history who done science
like if you look at if you do a bit of
research a lot of Muslims were involved
in mathematic algebra the form that
exactly so we Muslims were not it's not
like the church Christians we was
against it
Islam thank you one question I'll just
quickly answer the Quran is the only
scripture will also come back cuz it's
been memorized by millions but I know
what you're trying to say when it comes
to observable reality but what I'm
saying is even if we put all the
religions to aside we came back here a
billion years later we will still see
cause and effect we'll still look around
and say hold on a second uniformity
regularity in order for us to do science
we need these things so you're right but
guess what science will only lead us
closer to God because when you look at a
snowflake why does a snowflake have a
symmetrical pattern yeah well I mean no
I know you get what say there's so many
wherever you look from a nano level to a
micro level but I feel like you can just
I can just say that this is nature this
is the world but why not God why is it
nature but not God cuz I'm trying to
understand you call it nature Evolution
why can it not be like you know what dis
point to an intelligent design no but
it's just like if I'm if there is a God
I think he's evil okay good now talk
there is a go I just think that there's
so many terrible terrible things like
why would you create like insects that
like like feed off the eyes of children
and like disgusting diseases like very
very tired why why I understand that
like I understand there has to be some
like evil maybe whatever but there are
just some things what is going on we if
there is a God we're clearly just like
entertainment for it and he's just like
let me just create nonsense and just
laugh these IDI trying to figure out
that's how Darwin was Darwin had the
same problems as you and now look let me
tell you something the God that I
worship I do not believe is God that put
us here cuz Allah says in the Quran I
did not create you for play I did not
create you so I can just you know no no
no so what it is this for example we
believe that God Almighty has is also
the all knowing and is also the most
wise Let me Give an example there are
certain things that has happened in your
life in my life for example getting hit
by a car yeah it I don't think it was
pleasant so there's things that's
happened in my life but let me tell you
something there's things that I could
not comprehend and understand but once I
came out of that test I truly understood
what it did it for me now you cannot
know what's beautiful until you see
what's ugly so for example when we talk
about yeah he needs yeah when we talk
about good and bad my dear sister
because you do not believe in a life
after death the god that we worship we
say for example like there's it see that
picture there imagine that was a drawing
painted by someone yeah I will know a
lot about the painter by looking at a
picture why because I know number one
that painter exists he will to paint
that number three is good at what he
does number four oh my go look at the
attention to detail I know so much about
the painter just by looking at the
picture so so what you're saying is by
looking at the earth and the design you
get to know the design yes do you know
do you know what I know number one the
universe began to exist the there's a
being that exists number two he had to
will the universe to exist number three
there is information in the universe he
has to be the all knowing number four
coming to what you said there is evil in
the world if there's evil that means God
has to be the all wise don't necessarily
believe in evil and good either I think
um I'm not going to get I don't it's not
nihilism it's one of them I'm not going
to get it right but it's where they just
don't they think that we are essentially
giving some kind of label to things but
like nothing is actually good or bad and
it's just yes yes so so I I did a bit of
research in this but you're talking
about for example when it comes to
morality there is no good or bad yeah
okay but when you go down that route
what's the difference between me eating
a chocolate but and killing somebody
they are rearrangement of atoms this is
when then has no value that's why if you
look at Hitler he believed in Eugenics
Eugenics means the greater R you get
what I'm trying to say so then that's
why a lot of atheists and a lot of
atrocities when you look at the killing
atheist have killed more well
Christianity Christianity is number one
then it's like without the minut he
starts saying that morality only exists
because objective morality yeah but if
you say that only exists because of
religion then that I think that's a
really dangerous road to go down cuz
then it's like okay then if you aren't
religious would you be like do you know
like I don't have I don't have a
religion I don't believe in any God I'm
not following
anything and I've gone out and murdered
as many people as I wanted to would say
Z people exactly don't want exactly I I
I don't think it's fair to say that for
example just cuz someone's an atheist
that means they are more PR to do evil
cuz there are religious people do more
evil than any atheist good so I'm not
I'm not even making that won't be fair
what I'm saying is the following though
in order for us to have objective
morality we need it to come from a
source that is objective that is free
from public human opinion so with us for
example today you would agree that for
example homosexuality is fine good look
okay uh trans somebody and a child
identifying and saying I Feel Like a
Woman child maybe a little bit more why
okay do you remember we went to morality
there is no good or bad because I feel
like there's certain level of in
influence and it's like I think that's
of a dangerous road to go down but when
it comes to people identifying as um
whatever they want to identify as I
personally feel like just you only get
to live once do what you want to do you
know like we we we we follow that
lifestyle as well we believe you only
live once do as many Good Deeds as you
can it's different way but what we say
is this like for example what about
incest oh like like like imagine imagine
a a brother and sister having intimacy
you know what that is obviously very
disgusting and I personally think that's
really wrong however I actually wouldn't
be able to back it up like especially if
they not going to be able to have
children I would it's actually they're
not it's victimless so it's a bit like
and if they love each other because when
it comes to Love Is Love why does the
lgbqt community not adopt eye in there
instead of you get what I'm trying to
say and say for incest cuz love is love
but do you see they even draw a line and
say to be fair no cuz then it like
creates really it's it's not good for
use prote no I know but it's not good
for society it's not good for like
families and um just sort of like
mentally as well it's really it's really
bad there there are studies that show
like for example same C same sex couples
like the the the how the children
perform it's it's it's very similar uh
like they don't perform really well same
set couples as well but the point I'm
saying is this that's why we need
objective morality cuz otherwise
everything like if you lived in Nazi
Germany me and you may have been like
you know what that's great what they did
to the Jews so that's why well exactly
so that's why we need objective morality
to tell us right from wrong and it comes
from an objective source so my argument
is not sure is this from morality to
rationality to where things come from
from cause and effect to all of these
things a higher being makes perfect
sense it's not a matter of leap of faith
and as a person who does science and
believes in science that should rather
tell you like a flagellum closer to
God yeah guess I don't know I just I
just don't believe in that's that's
that's fine that's anyone could really
convince me the only I think the only
religion that I would ever potentially
join is Buddhism because I don't really
see as religion I see as more of like a
philosophy um they don't really
necessarily believe in a God or a how
they they have elements of like carala
and connectivity and things um how like
your actions have consequences and all
that stuff yeah um so I think that for
me is quite okay that's good I mean I
would say don't put every religion into
the same category a lot of people do it
like they leave Christianity and they
think oh Islam is probably just the same
I would say give it a chance cuz I came
to Islam 11 years ago and I read all
religions I just really wanted to Deep
dive into it and the Quran I chose the
Quran because number one it's been
preserved has been change number two it
has evidences within it to prove its
existence why is from God Almighty it's
not a blind faith of close eyes I think
it's definitely a bit more powerful than
Christianity even then yeah I definitely
have a bit of complicated relationship
with Islam I'm Persian and like
situation is interesting and I see I see
I see I see are you are you Iranian yeah
okay okay yeah that's F I understand the
thing but my mom is like yeah
for left that
country and we we are against the regime
and like you know certain things that
they do Etc you like any yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so so yeah not 100% but I
would say do not take God out thect
believe me there is sufficient and more
than enough evidence that DNA that
you're talking about the fact the way
you look the way you look and the way I
look my eyes your teeth all of these
things it's not random mutation it is
targeted mutation because do you get
what I'm trying to say because the cells
communicate with each other and that's
the reason why which shows you that
there has to be intelligent design Now
new scientists are coming out saying
look there has come on I mean there's
intelligent designer there's things
working in order yeah but no like thank
you sister any questions for me anything
my stud I just wanted to say like thank
you for obviously like I'm I don't think
I'm going to like overnight convert to
Islam or anything but one day um but but
um I do love listening to your own
passion and your I think that way me as
well thank you sister thank you I really
appreciate it we're here every Friday
and Sunday if you ever want to come and
talk um feel free thank you sister take
care
bye-bye I mean I'll be honest with you
that was uh one of the most holistic
discussions I had intelligence she knew
she knew she knew about the DNA Etc and
it was good because you know when he
talk to some people they don't know what
you're talking about it was good she was
like no this that that Etc but again it
further proved that God Almighty exists
alhamdulillah so brother and sisters
aldah as you can see this is why da is
so important oh my gosh it's quarter 7
uh I don't think we're going to be
having a hot chocolate today chabi in 45
minutes if we raise a Target we might do